hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today i'm
going to explain a 2020 american science
fantasy movie called secret society of
second born royals
the movie begins in illyria the smallest
country in europe where samantha the
second daughter of the royal family of
illyria isn't treated like a princess
since she is not the eldest daughter in
the family however her older sister
eleanor always gets whatever she wants
to make things worse for sam her father
the king of illyria died in a plane
crash with his brother therefore sam's
mother catherine took over the throne to
lead the country under her command in a
few weeks eleanor is going to turn 18
and she will be crowned as the queen of
illyria to replace her mother while
sam's presence is never considered in
the family
living her life as a normal kid sam
hangs out with anyone one of them is
mike the son of a groundskeeper in the
kingdom since the country adopts a
moniker-y system they conduct an
anti-moniker campaign by performing rock
music on the streets attracting people
nearby and the police officer
sam attempts to distract the cops with
her skateboard skill but she eventually
hits a traffic sign and gets arrested
she is then brought back to her mom in
the palace where she explains that
people are unhappy with the government
system but catherine denies that saying
that they are just a minority
the next day at school she comes across
another second born royal named roxanna
who is quite popular and loves to do
live streaming
the scene moves to a high security
prison that is specifically built for
the most notorious criminals in the
world
there two guards are seen delivering
food to a man called inmate 34. he finds
a capacitor hidden inside an apple and
installs it to a device that allows him
to break free from the neck cuff
he regains his power and uses his
telekinesis power to break the door and
escapes from the facility
meanwhile mike and sam are practicing in
a music studio for their concert inside
the palace the boy invites sam to come
to the bramble bone concert with him
which she agrees to he is surprised and
confused when sam manages to smell the
garlic naan in his mouth which he ate
two days ago sam comes across the old
stuff of her and her father and recalls
the memory of her father used to call
him snowflakes because she was so
special to him that night she attends a
pre-event before the coronation of
eleanor and suddenly remembers that she
has promised mike to come to a party
with him she lies to her mother
immediately changes her appearance into
a rock girl and then catches up with
mike
however since both of them don't have id
cards they are forbidden to enter the
building they luckily come across the
workers at the back door and sam somehow
manages to see the guy entering the
door's passcode from a distance which
surprises mike they then get into the
building and enjoy the party where sam
suddenly is able to hear every sound
that is occurring in the club including
heartbeat and the sound of insect
buzzing
she feels uncomfortable and dizzy at the
same time forcing her to trigger the
fire alarm to stop the concert because
of that they get arrested again
mike realizes that something is wrong
with his friend since that moment when
she was able to smell what he had had
for lunch two days ago not long after
they are released and are picked up by
their parents
catherine decides to send her daughter
to a summer school to make up for
missing her test
meanwhile inmate 34 secretly calls his
partner praising him or her for the
apple idea it is revealed that catherine
is the one who put him in the cell while
waiting for his move he keeps
strengthening his telekinesis skill and
secretly stalks sam the next day she
attends the summer school where she
meets january claiming that her dad was
friends with sam's uncle there is also a
socially awkward mateo tuma and of
course the popular roxanna a few moments
later the teacher responsible for the
summer class professor james morrow
shows up at the class he then reveals
that each of them is a second born royal
and they secretly possess a unique
superpower without them realizing he
adds that the purpose of the summer
school is to train them to join the
secret society of second-born royals
turns out that catherine is the head of
the society program which shocks sam
she explains that the society was formed
to protect the monarchies from threats
and criminals all around the world the
bad news is the students who do not pass
the training will have their memory
erased and they won't remember that they
have the superpower they begin their
first training where they are ordered to
reach the pyramid however it's not as
easy as it seems the room is filled with
laser weapons which shoot the cocky tuma
slow but sure the students begin to
discover their own superpower one by one
roxanna realizes that she has the power
to be invisible while tuma's power is to
influence people to do whatever he
commands
on the other hand sam's supersense makes
her to be more sensitive to surroundings
allowing her to act faster than the
others
long story short all of the students are
beaten by the first challenge
after that january discovers her
superpower which allows her to steal
others power temporarily by touching
them while mateo manages to control
insects after the session the girls
share their problems as the second born
in the family to each other when sam's
backup phone suddenly rings the next day
the students continue their training
where jamex explains that they need to
be able to control their powers
because they have a unique superpower
james assigns a specialized training for
each of them
sam is told to focus on voices to
sharpen her super senses while tuma is
given a dog named charlie to improve his
interactions with others on the other
side roxanna is forced to bring out her
superpower under the extreme weather
while mateo is practicing his control
over the insects
january is brought to a swimming pool
where she has to maintain her stolen
power from anna whose ability is
breathing underwater james even tests
his students in lunch by deliberately
bringing sam poison food to sharpen her
senses
january then shares her favorite apple
to her that night mike's dad spots his
son calling the princess he advises him
not to get too close to the royals
because they are not on his level the
next day sam approaches her mother who
surprisingly shows her an underground
headquarters where a lot of unique stuff
is stored there
one of them is a dna based nano device
that can target specific people with
specific genetic sequences catherine
gives her some tricks to master her
superpower after that all of the
students have managed to master their
own superpower except roxanna sam
manages to guess correctly some of the
voices mateo is getting better at
controlling the bees charlie obeys
tuma's orders and january hits her best
records in holding breath underwater
since roxanna is the one who is not
progressing james deliberately threatens
to do a live streaming of her with messy
hair and no makeup with this trick
roxanna eventually manages to bring out
his invisibility power the students
eventually have reached their peak and
james is very happy with the result
later that night sam is supposed to do a
street concert with mike however james
suddenly awakens the students forcing
them to do their very first mission to
protect a jewel from being stolen they
arrive at the location and sam manages
to spot the thief with her super senses
they chase after the thief only to find
out that she is actually january's coach
they have been tricked and failed to
protect the jewel james is disappointed
with them and decides to cancel the
following day's training
sam apologizes to mike for not coming
but she is prohibited from telling him
what is happening to her right now which
makes him upset the next day because
it's their free day they decide to go on
a short vacation to the beach
after having fun sam is getting closer
with january and she invites her to the
palace they sneak in and she shows
january her dedicated music studio where
she reveals that her dad purposely
converted the tower into the studio only
for her
suddenly mike shows up at the studio and
is totally upset when he learns that sam
is having fun without him a few moments
later inmate 34 appears and attacks the
students with telekinesis before he runs
away she hears him call her snowflake an
alias only her father called her james
orders them to calm down but sam
disobeys and chases after him she
manages to locate him in the woods where
james tries to protect sam but gets
severely beaten up he reveals to sam
that he is her uncle edmund just before
january arrives and punches him away
with the stolen power the teacher is
hospitalized catherine eventually has to
reveal the truth to her daughter
explaining that edmund killed her father
to seize the throne that's why she
locked him up in the prison
sam demands to see edmund figuring out
that he is indeed her uncle he explains
that his real motive was to tear down
the monarchy so that people could live
equally he lost his patience waiting for
sam's father to make change so he
murdered him she then beats her older
sister who tells sam that she will bring
change to the kingdom as soon as she
becomes the queen meanwhile the students
agree to attend eleanor's coronation to
support sam
that night sam decides to visit james at
the hospital
she apologizes to him and he forgives
her the coronation day has come where
every single important royal in the
world is attending the event however
tuma is somehow unable to use his
superpower there while january equipped
herself with persuasive superpower
stolen from tuma silently sneaks into
the underground headquarters
she orders the guard to free edmund from
his custody and it is revealed that she
was the one who did the apple trick
she then gets back to her friends
ordering them to follow her and lock
them inside the cell
mateo informs sam about january through
one of his b's with her super senses she
manages to track edmund and immediately
chases after him the ceremony is now in
progress and edmund arrives at the
cathedral setting up a nano device that
will wipe out everyone with a royal
bloodline
meanwhile sam realizes that january is
going after her so she runs to mike's
house and asks for his help at first he
refuses to help her but sam apologizes
and reveals her secret to him they
eventually team up and manage to take
out january who admits that she made a
deal with edmund so that she could rule
they regroup with the other students and
decide to stop edmund together he claims
that a world without royals will give
freedom to other people
sam tuma and roxanna managed to distract
him and successfully lure him to a room
where a miniaturized chamber has been
installed to weaken his telekinesis
mike reprogrammed the nano device which
eventually traps edmund inside on the
other side the coronation is completed
without any distraction and eleanor has
officially become illyria's new queen
sam roxanna mateo and tuma finally get
accepted into the society as james
recovers from his injuries
catherine reveals the secret society to
the new queen who promises to sam that
she will give the people of illyria a
choice by adding parliament alongside
the monarchy the society is informed
that january has escaped and challenges
them to find her
with their newest suit they proceed to
the next mission
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching